I can look in practice in practice 99%
will be natural one because it's not
that interesting else yeah to not do it
but it's not hard to do it if the base
is not is the base is naughty because
you can change the base to eat it very
easily right so how do I change this
space to make it base e okay so you say
well the top one will be X and the
bottom one we - right so V log X on long
- no no because log 2 is a number it's a
constant I don't know what it is five
point six something something something
okay
so I might as well put you know three or
two that's not a quotient rule that's
just a function with a number at the
front that one alone - right it's just
the closet so then it's the derivative
of log X so 1 over X ok so can they ask
you of course they can't because you're
mention no change of base rule you're
meant to marry how to take this out and
differentiate it that's fine
but I honestly can't remember the last
time I saw one of these that's how rare
they are but should you be prepared for
it
well when preparing for it is only three
lines I think you can manage reverse the
eczema - so what we different shape is
like that exactly the same way give me a
little worse but it's going to be okay
that's the derivative off want to on
love X okay so I'm going to take the log
two out of front and then this is low
sign wallet x ^ -1 so that it becomes
chain rule of changeable just one change
actually that's just do it it's okay
differentiate the outside ok so what do
I do
power out the front reduce the power by
1 and then you multiply by the inside
okay so that's a minus log on X